[Música]
porque me dio una alta expectativa el
presidente electo de chile gabriel boric
presentó su gabinete ministerial un
equipo conformado por una fuerte
presencia de mujeres aunque el
presidente electo ya había anunciado que
su gobierno sería paritarios sorprendió
el hecho de que 14 ministerios un total
de 24 sean liderados por mujeres la
fuerte presencia femenina se debe a la
promesa de campaña que hizo boris de
construir un gobierno feminista uno de
los nombres más simbólicos de estos
nombramientos es el de ischia sitges
quien será la primera mujer en ocupar el
cargo de ministra del interior en la
historia de chile y por ello entonces
saludo a nuestra primera invitada al día
ella es marta lagos analista
internacional socióloga y directora de
la encuesta regional latino barómetro
gracias por estar con nosotros marta en
directo américa de france 24 le pregunta
entonces la lectura que se le puede dar
a este gabinete de ministros que lo hace
feminista además por supuesto de que la
mayoría sean mujeres esto asegura que
sea un gobierno realmente feminista como
lo afirmó entonces el presidente electo
gabriel boric
bueno en primer lugar el gabinete es un
gabinete que con el cual se inicia una
nueva época un nuevo ciclo político está
claro que chile stop o fondo en la
elección presidencial con una crisis
política profunda y este gobierno
simboliza un poco la salida de esa
crisis no y sale de la crisis con esta
gigantesca demanda
feminista que tuvo chile en el año
1915 corrió el mundo con las famosas
tesis y que ha tenido mucha fuerza hoy
día ningún ningún varón en este país se
atreve a decir que no está a favor de la
equidad de género y está este gabinete
es el resultado de eso marta dentro de
este caminito también estaba quienes lo
acompañaron unas protestas
universitarias hablemos del año 2011
entre ellas a camila vallejo que podemos
decir de camila y en las digamos las
ministras más claves y las que más
suenan en chile dentro de chile
bueno esta generación que tiene 35 años
junto con el presidente hicieron la
revolución estudiantil del año 2011 y en
una década
salieron llegaron de la calle se puede
decir como estudiantes a la moneda es
una carrera vertiginosa para la historia
de chile
camila vallejo fue presidenta de la
federación de estudiantes más grande del
país de la universidad de chile
y que asiste en mi futura ministra del
interior primera mujer en ese cargo fue
presidenta del colegio médico durante la
pandemia con gran liderazgo
en los momentos más críticos no es
cierto entonces estas dos mujeres que
van a liderar este gobierno junto con el
presidente tiene una trayectoria y un
conocimiento digamos de la población muy
muy
acabado decir nadie puede decir que no
las conoce no conoce su trayectoria lo
que han hecho a lo largo de su vida me
parece que ahí hay una un grupo en el
comité político del palacio de la moneda
que
que tiene un concepto muy claro muy muy
desarrollado muy
concreto no cierto de lo que quieren de
lo que quieren conseguir es un equipo es
un equipo potente
marta qué retos tiene este nuevo
gobierno con qué país se enfrenta y
además le digo si ya tiene la confianza
de la mayoría de los chilenos de que las
cosas van a cambiar y que las cosas van
a salir bien con ese nuevo gobierno del
presidente electo gabriel boric
bueno américa latina en el continente
más desconfiado de la tierra y chile es
uno de los países más desconfiados de
ese continente y en la mitad de la
crisis política que estamos en los
niveles de confianza en este país han
bajado a sus a sus puntos más más
mínimos no por lo tanto el tema de la
confianza en el gobierno lo iremos
viendo a medida que el gobierno va
ganándose esa confianza aquí hay que
ganarse cada punto de confianza en este
momento hay una expectativa hay una
tremenda esperanza hay una luna de miel
con grandes digamos resultados positivos
pero el gobierno aún no empieza entonces
habrá que esperar a ver si la
ciudadanía le entrega
un periodo de luna de miel con algunos
grados de confianza a este nuevo
presidente pero como digo uno de los
problemas más grandes que tiene américa
latina' hoy día es la desconfianza este
gobierno tiene más confianza que los
otros pero veremos cuál es el nivel que
tiene así es marta le quería preguntar
entonces pasados dos años del estallido
social que tuvo chile cómo está el país
hoy este gobierno representa el cambio
que realmente querían los chilenos y
además cómo se va a enfrentar este nuevo
gobierno a la constituyente a esta
reforma en la constitución chilena
también producto este estallido social
del año 2019
bueno este gobierno le va a tocar
promulgar la nueva constitución y hacer
el plebiscito de salida concierto y
empezar a implementar los cambios que la
nueva constitución traiga entonces
enfrentamos dos tipos de cambio unos son
los cambios estructurales producidos por
las reformas que va a proponer este
gobierno como la reforma de de pensiones
y la reforma tributaria que serían las
dos más importantes y lo otro es el
cambio
institucional no es cierto que está
promoviendo o que se visualiza que va a
promover en la nueva constitución
pareciera que es un poco mucho no es un
poco mucho para un pueblo de aceptar
esto pero la verdad es que hay una
tremenda demanda de salir del hoyo que
estamos estamos empantanados
económicamente políticamente socialmente
y estos cambios son necesarios
y poder salir de ese deseo yo ahora a lo
mejor a los extranjeros les parece raro
que una chilena diga que estamos
empantanados pero es la percepción que
hay al interior del país cómo se puede
salir de esto marta digamos en los
primeros 100 días de este nuevo gobierno
encabezado por gabriel boric que tendría
que hacer para pues tener un país mucho
mejor del que está dejando el saliente
sebastián piñera
pero yo creo que aquí hay que proceder
un poco como procedió el presidente lula
en brasil no no se trata de cambiar
todas las circunstancias porque todo el
mundo sabe que eso no es posible aquí no
existe la hada madrina pero si es
posible señalar que los grupos más
discriminados y más desiguales tengan un
avance es decir que ese avance se se
concrete en alguna parte en algún grupo
eso fue lo que hizo lula con su proyecto
'hambre cero'
que le produjo el 80 por ciento de
aprobación
al inicio de la década del 2000 no
entonces me parece que es un buen
ejemplo para decir bueno como se sale de
un hoyo se sale
imagínense tres líneas al interior de un
túnel dolor los pobres están en la línea
del al lado derecho están estancados en
el medio del túnel sin ninguna
expectativa de llegar a la boca
lo que tiene que hacer el presidente
boris es hacer avanzar esa línea que
está estancada
muerto yo básicamente
básicamente eso no con algunas reformas
que impliquen un impacto directo y
concreto sobre esas poblaciones más
rezagadas marta ya para finalizar
también hay un grupo de chilenos digamos
internamente preocupados por la línea
izquierda del presidente boris
internacionalmente va a tener estos
aliados de izquierdas fuertes en la
región latinoamericana
mire a ver
e izquierda sí pero bueno la propuesta
del presidente boris es bastante
parecida a la de la economía social de
mercado alemana no el hecho de que el
empresariado chileno diga que el
presidente boris es muy cercano al
comunismo demuestra el grado de atraso
ideológico y de digamos civilizatorio
que tiene el empresariado el
empresariado chileno nosotros tenemos un
estado que necesita más dinero y sin una
reforma tributaria no no podemos seguir
llegando al desarrollo entonces si es un
gobierno de izquierda pero está muy
lejos de ser lo cierto esa izquierda
quien no es responsable económicamente
que no tiene equilibrio macroeconómico
que no piensa que está involucrada y en
insertar en la globalización entonces sí
me parece que ahí hay una diferencia y
puede significar una diferencia en el
giro de lo que la izquierda significa en
américa latina' precisamente por esa
diferencia